so in contrast to tolstoy
uh let me ask you about emma goldman you
wrote that
if anarchism believed in rulers then
emma goldman would be the undisputed
queen yes
what uh ideas define her flavor of
anarchism
would you say emma was really
an old school radical she was a radical
among radicals
i don't know what ideas i mean what
would diabetes would find her was
anarchism
obviously there's the violence i mean
she was more
open to the idea of violent opposition
versus somebody like tolstoy oh sure for
sure so basically emma and alexander
berkman their mentor was someone named
johann most
and johann most was a very early free
speech not very early but he was a free
speech concern because he published a
pamphlet in europe
that was translated in the states about
how to build dynamite
because his idea was all right you have
this oppressive government this
oppressive police force
that use batons and bolts against us
the only way for us as the working class
to level the playing field
is through dynamite and here's how you
build it so the question is all right
is this something that could be allowed
to be legal now that you're allowing the
layman to in his own house build bombs
so uh johann most turn basically they
had a big parting of wazed
because when alexander berkman tried to
assassinate a
frick johann said no no this is not
something i'm for and in fact they
thought
with this assassination this failed
assassination this would be the thing
that
fired off the revolution because you had
the strike the pinkerton's interval
pinker's getting killed
strikers are getting killed you know
this is what marx predicted you know
they're going to
light the spark and everything's come
falling down he ends up going to jail
for 13 years instead alexander brookman
does
and then goldman and berkman had a big
issue
because when leon salgaz killed mckinley
in 1901
it was really it's kind of humorous in
retrospect he gets arrested and they're
like why'd you kill the president he
goes
i was radicalized by emma goldman and
she's like god damn it
so she's on the run she's like i don't
even know this guy
and she made the point about like
why is it worse than the president being
killed in somebody else we're all equal
and you would think if you're against
capitalism against the ruling class this
would be your first target
but berkman who went to jail who's tried
to assassinate someone he had said
mckinley this is your villain he's just
a party hack he's like a symptom of the
times
this is this is foolish and goldman
disagreed with him she thought it wasn't
necessarily um justified but it may have
done
something that was defensible so the
three of them uh
you know had their differences on the
use of violence and in fact when she
came back from russia
and was denouncing it in her book my
disillusionment in russia and my further
solution rostra
the last chapter she goes look i'm not
saying i'm against violence
i when there's the revolution comes
we're going to have to use force she
goes
but it's not the force of the state
against the working class against the
masses this is exactly what we're
opposed to this is a complete
obscenity to our principles so that was
interesting the fact that she was a
her periodical mother earth was a
clearinghouse for many prominent
uh you know ideas of the day that
weren't anarchists but were certainly
radical so she was a bit and also she
was like tiny she was like 5-1
so to have this little woman who was so
feisty
um and talk back to lenin talk back to
lennon uh
would she took on lenin woodrow wilson
jander hoover was the one who deported
her
uh someone who just and the thing is you
have to be careful
because i think just like war it's very
easy to glamorize
violence and to regard it as something
admirable or heroic like you're fighting
for the cause
but if you take it out of the
romanticism you're like you're killing
someone who had kids you are you know
killing someone with the family
you're making your if you're gonna shoot
someone they're probably gonna retaliate
twice as hard
violence sings its own song and this is
a very dangerous word you're going down
so you you really need to be uh careful
about what you're what you're preaching
here
um and you know she kind of had this
mixed feelings about it but
that is certainly not uh emma goldman
her best
emma goldman of her best was about the
ultimate freedom of the individual
of caring about people who are
desperately poor
who despised the corporate idea that we
all had to be made
cookie cutters um and be interchangeable
and all have to start work at the same
time
and basically our entire lives slave or
corporation that have nothing to show
for it
while they get wealthy and you you have
no opportunity for either
productive work or creative work so that
i think the valorization
of kind of the lowest of the low is
something i find very admirable
there's a quote of hers which i think
even for those of us who are you know
for
property rights is anarchist left
anarchism at its best but she goes
go and ask for work if they don't give
you work
ask for bread if they don't give you
bread take bread
so the idea that like if you're that
poor and you're honestly trying to work
and work isn't available
and you steal food to keep alive that
you shouldn't feel guilt about it
i don't know that i would disagree with
that i think that there's something to
be said at that point where it's just
like
you know if property rights come between
that and mass starvation
it's going to be very hard for anyone to
make the case for property rights now my
argument is
when you have free enterprise food
becomes so plentiful that now obesity is
an issue
but at the time she did not of course
have that data to
you know access
you